all right Mike's working great thank you
guys for being here this afternoon I
know it's a last talk of the day before
the lightning talks um hopefully this is
really cool and exciting if it's not
that's on you cuz this is really
exciting to me you know talk about
deploying machine learning using SK
learn pipelines my name is Kevin Goetsch
I'm at grub hub I was at Braintree and
Allstate before that I'm really into
using Python in my machine learning what
is this talk about
pipeline is an overused term every
freaking library uses this term I'm
going to talk about a very specific
pipeline it's a technique inside of a
library SK learn inside of a language
Python that I'm using to do machine
learning if I say pipeline I'm referring
to this one thing not all the other uses
of pipeline throughout the entire
programming community all right well
good with that why are you watching this
I'm gonna guess that maybe you want to
understand how to build pipelines and
when to use them yeah all right maybe
want to learn how to do smooth
development and deployment
this one's written a lot of very good
data scientists not know how to use
pipelines and it's really simple and
it's really helpful and I would love to
have you guys use it because it makes it
way easier to deploy your work you might
also be my father trying to understand
what I do at work every day I am so
sorry dad this is not gonna really help
we're just gonna keep working on that
here's the roadmap for the talk we're
gonna talk about what pipelines are I'm
going to give you a modeling example
we're gonna do kind of a piece by piece
walk through what goes inside of a
pipeline then we're gonna kind of check
in make sure we're good then we're going
to talk about the life cycle of data
science mainly development followed by
deployment we're just gonna wrap it up
yeah use a PC it's kind of a chicken in
the egg problem you kind of have to
understand the like life cycle to
understand how that fits together so I'm
just gonna plunge in where I'm gonna
plunge in we're all gonna go with it and
by the end I hope it all comes together
if it doesn't I love questions as all my
co-workers who are here know what our SK
learned pipelines a container of steps
what are steps the main ones here [ __ ]
estimate
did my mic cut out nope we're good um
pipelines are used to package a workflow
and package fit model objects all
together into a single serializable
object I'm sure they're used for lots of
other things this is the talk today
missus I know cool alright so I'm gonna
do a quick visual because this is
actually how I think of it when I start
building pipelines um they're like Legos
you're just stacking little component
pieces together one of the big
advantages of using pipelines and all of
their component steps is that it is
super modular you can actually just take
out and put in different pieces this is
literally I visualize it like this um so
we have an estimator it's gonna be this
salmon covered box it's just an
estimator sitting there it maybe takes
an input maybe has an output let's not
worry too much about it it's a little
Lego block right now all right
there's also maybe a transformer the
transformer does some sort of
transformation they are kind of sitting
on top of each other but they're not
actually squished together yet there's
no communication between these two right
now the pipeline is what snaps them
together right and pipeline snap thing
together
tall wise we're just talking about
stacking Lego blocks right here um it
doesn't really matter to the pipeline
what's inside of it as long as it can
just transform and pass the output of
one to the input of the next on down the
line
there are two towers two pipelines right
but he's just stacked side-by-side
they're not actually communicating
across hopefully we all see there's
going because there's a fourth part and
that just fits the two together right so
feature Union just really joins the
result of whatever steps are inside of
it in this case inside of this feature
Union there are two pipelines so the
output of each of those pipelines are
getting joined together inside of each
of those pipelines there's an estimator
in a transformer we're just this visual
right here fixed in memory good cuz I'm
gonna actually look at some code next
it's gonna be simpler than this but this
is conceptually what we're doing we're
just stacking Lego blocks
we're just joining their output so I
wish I had an example as cool as that
Eve one in the room next door last talk
that was really cool I'm gonna use the
Titanic data set kind of a classic
trying to predict who would survive the
sinking of the Titanic based on data
we're even going to use a single
predictive variable we're gonna keep it
super simple to illustrate my points did
we just make sense I'm the one with the
mic so I actually don't know all right
so we're gonna do this in a non pipeline
my classical just Python I'm not gonna
lie I just copied this code off the
internet it was from Kaggle thank you
whoever wrote it I had a thing written
about them earlier but it disappeared so
response variable you guys can look it
up it's like the first-year response
very the night you survived I'm gonna
load some training data I'm going to
find median age of the truth all ages
that weren't null grab the median age
and then this nice little if length of
training blah blah blah that's just
going to replace all no values of the
age with that median age all right so we
don't have any nulls we've just assigned
the median we've made this choice
feature engineering maybe keeps flashing
I'm not sure if it's up there and then
we're going to drop all the calls that
aren't relevant to our model all right
so we're just predicting survived we're
just using this one variable age which
has been adjusted
neat now I'm gonna load some test data
I'm gonna do the exact same thing find
the median age do the replacement drop
the other variables I'm gonna start a
random forest classifier I'm gonna give
it a random state so that we can
actually do this on the pipeline world
and get exactly the same answers to
prove my point it'll be awesome I'm
gonna fit I'm going to call predict prob
a on my test data I fit on my train data
this should all sound familiar to most
people after all these talks people
really explained it much better than I
have
I hope cuz oh yeah I'm embarrassed but
it's fine
so I'm gonna redo all of that work with
the pipeline to recall the output of
this thing is called forest output
really into very explicit variable names
all right so here's a here's we're doing
it with a pipeline we have a response
variable we're gonna read in both
training and test then I'm going to call
this function make pipeline as you can
tell from the how many times I've said
pipeline so far I'm going to go more
into this later we're gonna kind of take
this as a thing for now but this is the
Lego blocks again right you can see
visually there's four steps right I have
something called a factor extractor
which does age I have a fill in a which
I hand this training median age umm I
converted back to a data frame at least
that's what I hope the function that
says convert to data frame does then I
hand it a random forest classifier right
so in essence I've formed a pipeline
around these four blocks one stacked on
top of each other that's all I did um I
haven't actually done anything with it
until I called pipeline fit now it's a
fit pipeline object and then pipeline
output or pipe output is pipeline dot
predict prob a on DF test data
you'll recall that earlier when I was
doing the normal training I had to like
say which variables to hand off this
sort of thing the pipeline is doing that
by having a factor extractor alright so
they should match right and they don't
and then I was writing this presentation
last night because they gave me like
three days to write it which meant I
played video games for like two days and
then I wrote it yesterday so this kind
of freaked me out last night I was like
did I not understand what I was skipping
a talk on but then it turned to out to
illustrate my point
I'm earlier when we were doing this
manually we said median age is equal to
the test
data frame age drop n/a so don't count
the Noles
that median
took me a while but I realized that the
test data frame median age is not the
same as the training data friend median
age right 27 and 28 this is just like a
random sample of tests and train easy
mistake to make I definitely made it I
definitely missed it but it serves to
illustrate my point really well you
don't make this mistake in the pipeline
right I didn't manually reapply my
training when I instituted this pipeline
I gave it one median age
right I just said give it the training
median age and then it was fixed when I
called it on the test set it just used
that same median age the same
transformations were applied in both
cases um this is one of those things
that could you do this without a
pipeline that's a common theme in my
talk you can do all of this without SK
learned five lines there's nothing like
unique about this it just saves you
hassle I'm reality is really hard and
complicated and I'm really lazy so if
you can save hassle and be right more
often oh my gosh so nice so we ran it
all right fix that median age bug and
the pipeline and forest output are true
it's super common yeah I guess this
exact mistake is common didn't take me
more than five minutes to find in the
code but if there were maybe 20
variables with some more complicated
interactions and maybe they were spread
across like two days worth of work and
maybe a co-worker did part of it like
this is where it starts getting
complicated
can you Institute really good
programming practices to avoid this of
course you can do you trust your
co-workers to do that no you you
probably shouldn't I don't really trust
pass Kevin to do that and you know it's
me so modeling this is the code wrapper
part I only had to write out my
transformers my whole SK learned
pipeline I wrote it once right it was
one place easy to find easy for me to
read it's also easy to swap out pieces
if I decided median age wasn't right I
wanted maybe just mean age it's what I
wanted um
BAM I just swap it out in the pipeline
definition if I wanted to do it in a
classical example I'm now doing it in
two places and two places sound like way
more work than doing it in one place and
you can multiply this out by all your
different types of things but in the end
it's just simplifying your work
simplifying your workflow readability
yeah I do curse past Kevin many times
converting all my work to pipe lines has
reduced the amount of cursing past Kevin
it's really nice when you go back to
your work three months later and you
actually know what heck happened maybe
this is only my problem in which case
you guys are lucky
finally keeps all the intermediate steps
together this is the mistake we made
right like you want to keep these steps
in one place you don't want you'll be
really apps you want to just build once
and just apply consistently across all
your trainings
cool right so I promise it was kind of a
chicken in the egg so now we're gonna go
a little deeper I just kind of gave you
a make pipeline and expected you to
trust me on it we're gonna look at it a
little bit deeper though frankly Tom's
talk this morning was like more
complicated in the Transformer realm so
talk to him if you have questions he
apparently knows this much better than I
do what is a transformer right
transformer is one of our little blocks
I believe it was Green in my earlier
visualization um it's got several
methods it's got two main ones I want to
worry about that's got transform which
applies transformations to the data and
it's got fit it applies fit logic on X
most transformers don't really use fit
except for the example from Tom that was
awesome so this is just when you call
fit you're not doing anything in this
simple factor extractor and this is the
same factor extractor I used earlier you
give it a factor when you initialize it
I gave it a j-- as a string when you
call transform it's just going to return
to you the slice of data where age is
the column right there's nothing fancy
about this you can do it manually
they're the same thing we're just
subsidy dough why would we ever do this
because the world gets really
complicated really fast in this way if I
have a whole huge stack of Lego blocks
of transformations and fancy things
going on at the very top I just I know
what's going into it I can just say I
know age is going into this it's
suddenly like I'm doing this depends
when you don't do a proper drop column
or maybe you're rewriting drop these
particular columns and you miss one
you've misspelled it you miss capitalize
it suddenly you're feeding extra data in
your bug your own code just clarifies it
it's a little more verbose it's this a
lot especially with my workers who I
forced to kind of use this in their
deployments when do you start like doing
all your hacking and then when you
switch over yeah young I can see you
smiling when you switch over to actually
using pipelines and development and I
use this all throughout development it's
much easier for me to just put it in
this context to begin with estimator
that was the salmon covered box not
really going to go into it it's just a
general term for any SK learn object
that makes a prediction um
mainly it's got a fit method and a
predict method if you were paying
attention earlier I actually called
predict prob a there are definitely
other methods for the purpose of this
talk we're just kind of focused on like
you're fitting a model object and then
later you're calling a predict on that
model object that model object is
something like a random forest
classifier here's one instantiated it's
got a bunch of metadata with it that's
not really important it's actually just
an estimator as far as the pipeline is
concerned because let's talk about what
a pipeline is we're going to fast I've
been known to but I have way more slides
this time than ever before so I'm gonna
keep going um pipeline is a whole stack
of Transformers with an estimator at the
bottom is this universally true of
course not I will show you an example
later where it's very different and we
get into ensemble engine hierarchy
models but the classic example is a
bunch of Transformers with an estimated
at the bottom which is why pipelines
when you call transform they call fit
than transform on each step when you
call predict they just call transform on
each step is really important transform
transform transform transform and
predict on the final step so earlier you
saw my factor extractor it didn't have a
predict method I'm calling predict on
the pipeline the first object is this
factor extractor the pipeline is not
calling predict on it I put in just call
and transform alright cuz they're just
Lego blocks easy peasy
it's really useful make pipeline that
thing I called oh right so initialize
you pass a list of tuples with the name
of the transformer or estimator followed
by the actual object this gets really
verbose really fast if you use this a
lot they have a shortcut it's called
make pipeline it just skips that you
hand it a bunch of objects and it
creates that list I think I even did a
little code example so make pipeline our
earlier factor extractor fill na these
are all transformers convert to data
frame transform or hopefully you know
what converts a data frame looks like
mentally like it's a transformer in the
transform method it's like PD dot data
frame we're just returning that of the
data that you hand it on down the line
and then a random forest classifier
that's identical to this right factor
extractor actual object bambam
bam-bam-bam this I'm just lazy it's a
theme of my life definitely of my talk
this is faster that's why I use it it's
still super clear to read to me make
pipeline Future Union final thing
feature Union final these four different
steps that are contained within this
paradigm it's basically a horizontal
pipeline right pipelines are stacked up
tall feet reunions are just wide so
feature unions have a bunch of steps but
now they're in parallel and they're just
feeding the output together the main
thing you're gonna call is something
like transform which is going to call
fit than transform eventually you're
gonna call predict all of this kind of
stuff happens and kind of just glossing
over it the docks I find your super
readable but that could be an indication
of what kind of person I am I I think
it's really straightforward it's just
doing this same step that the pipeline
was doing if it doesn't look
straightforward I definitely didn't
think it was straightforward two years
ago um so it does take a little bit to
get in but this is used more and more
and so the more you see it the more you
can play with it I'm going to get to it
later but you can actually pull out each
individual brick of these towers and
play with them you you have access to
all of these objects it's not like
they're locked away from you so merge is
the final result um same initialization
name and transformer you can also call a
make feature Union caveat I've written a
dataframe Union class so I sometimes
slip up and call it one or the other
it's just the same as feature Union it
just outputs a data frame instead of an
umpire right I find it easier to work a
pan two data frames is it as performant
I have no idea I don't really care I
work with small enough data that it's
just easier for me um it was super
simple I just add their code I shouldn't
say simple took me actually weeks I was
really happy when I did it and their
code was super good that's what I should
say once I got into it and read it I was
very happy this is useful to me I would
happy to share it it should be useful to
others if they want it so let's talk
feature Union yeah we got a feature
Union right here feature Union equals
make data frame Union this is making one
of mine we can keep thinking as a
feature Union they're virtually
identical but this is that same little
visualization two objects inside of the
feature Union pipeline one pipeline to
right we're calling make pipeline
inside the pipeline one a transformer
followed by another transformer factor
extractor followed by fill anaise inside
pipeline - we have a factor extractor
followed by a fill na followed by
something I called categorical dumb
afire
this creates dummy variables for
categoricals I reuse this a lot it's a
pretty standard transformer
unlike Toms example with pandas other
people someone else went to town stock
right we're only two rooms okay unlike
git or I don't use git dummies I didn't
actually know that it had that like drop
first which looks like it was just
released in point one eight I use Patsy
which drops that first so we don't
really matter it's going to transform to
a categorical variable so we have our
training set just the first three rows
all we're going to do is we're going to
just call on our feature Union object
fit transform right and this is just two
different pipelines each pipeline is
doing its thing producing an output and
the data frame Union is joining them
together
yeah so what we get is sex true dot male
that's how Patsy writes its categorical
variables I mean it drops the female
variable because of right because
there's only two age
well doesn't actually look any different
because I didn't have any n A's in my
first three but it would been replaced
as well and the age column was produced
by the first pipeline in my future Union
sex was produced by the second pipeline
yeah this stuff's really really fun when
it starts just kind of clicking together
I think Legos are fun too though so okay
check-in we're all good you're now all
experts right we're all experts it's
only gonna get cooler from here in what
pipelines are you know kind of how to
build a basic pipeline it's called make
pipeline you also know kind of what each
piece of these are I hope if even if all
you take away is that did their Lego
blocks that's probably pretty cool next
up we're talking about data science life
cycle just generally especially with
development and deployment and kind of
where these pipelines are used all right
so as I advertised model development I
am probably not even going to talk about
cross validation some of the main steps
in ideal model development environment
feature engineering model selection
hyper parameter optimization cross
validation publishing the model probably
heard this a hundred times if you been
to talks like this if you've never heard
this before this is kind of be like
quintessential building a data science
model um in reality is way more chaotic
and just creative in my experience
because all kinds of things are changing
all the time but yeah again it can be
accomplished without pipeline so I don't
wanna you can do it however you want
pipelines are just a tool that I find
are easier for me
why I heart pipelines part 1 emojis are
hard in markdown at 11:00 p.m. last
night I could not get it to do an emoji
we're just gonna live with it as is
feature engineering reuse transformers
this is awesome I love this I use my
categorical dumb afire in all kinds of
projects right I have it in this chaired
data Science Library and I just import
it I don't have to reinvent how to do
this if I want to strip the dollar sign
out of like a dollars and cents column I
just have a light convert currency to
float I just call it all the time it
doesn't really matter where it was first
used because it's a standard one I have
a separate dictionary or dictionary
separate like transformer lists for very
specific projects that have weird
transformers that wouldn't be reused the
being able to reuse the Transformers
project your project is awesome if you
find a bug in one of them you can fix it
in all of your projects instantly um you
just also have more standard code you
can think about this once um again it's
just so impressed by Tom's talk with the
whole doing like a reverse transform
when you want or inverse transform when
you want to pull data back the other way
you only have to write that once in that
particular transformer and now you've
got it you've got it on all of your
projects that you're using this in write
readable transformation logic I find it
super readable you have a stack of these
things you don't have to find where in
the code this happened it's super
readable readability is really important
future you co-workers all of that apply
identical transformations to training in
tests remember that mistake I made
earlier this is just one of those many
gotchas and data science that you avoid
entirely by using the exact same feature
engineering pipeline like everything
comes through it's hard to mess up I can
still do it though don't trip yeah you
can put anything in a wrap on this is
something was this is a slightly
complicated and I'm gonna walk through
it line by line
so get ready or open your laptop's your
choice this is something that I
implemented 2d it extreme gradient
boosting as part of an ensemble egde
package in our modeling environment so
two things here one this extreme
gradient booster which is not a scalar
and paradigm
did not want to be the last thing so
thick wine this be the final thing this
is gonna be the Southwest thing but I
still needed it to produce a prediction
uh - it is not means I can't count on it
having fit Tran
we just can wrap it so we're gonna call
it a transformer mixin and a base
estimator this gets me some of these
fanciness where if I call fit transform
it will call fit then transform without
me having to think about it it also
provides things like get params on some
of the stuff that makes the internal
workings work nicer I just important
both of these or assign them do about
half my classes by default I'm not gonna
go into detail on those the actual
object right this is a transformer
object containing an extreme gradient
boosted model important distinction
differentiation um it's got a name it's
got a model object which is the actual
extreme gradient boosted libraries model
object and it's got an evaluation metric
and when you're calling predict down
through this pipeline
it doesn't natively pass an evaluation
metric I wanted to be super explicit so
I have it in here I assign it ahead of
time
should have backup Ensemble äj-- so
dataframe union multiple pipelines when
you combine the output that's an
ensemble is you could just take the
average of two pipelines outputs and
that would be a nun samba which you
could use somewhat thinking way more
advanced it doesn't really matter when
I'm saying Ensemble äj-- I just mean
taking multiple pipelines combining
their output let's just say an average
average is great it's super easy to
understand so back in here the fit
method I'm going to take the model
object
I'm gonna call fit on it when I fit it I
need to hand it this evaluation metric
and some arguments in this case the X
and y values now inside of this
transformer I now have a fit object so
when I call predict I need to call
predict on this object but when I call
predict it's going to call transform
transform transform just form and then
predict at the very end this is second
to the end so transform transform
transform transform means that when I
call predict I need transform to
actually call predict on the model right
that's why right here it has a transform
function it says in a data frame self
dot model dot predict on X it's also
going to name the column this model plus
underscore prediction so we have five
different pipelines they all kind of
look like this this is all their last
step that we're unioning up or taking
the average of at the end and each one's
going to predict model one prediction
model two prediction model three
prediction I'm just going to sum them up
take the average what have you yeah I'm
really excited about this this is cool
because you can use anything if you have
some if you want to get crazy and it's
really crazy but if you want to go like
are two pi like you can use anything in
here you just wrap it and suddenly
you're calling it right it's super
systematic where it's just calling this
transform you know exactly what it's
doing there's nothing really complicated
under the hood here yeah all right I get
excited about a lot of strange things
model selection this is still part of
development these things are super
modular you can take out pieces put in
other pieces if I didn't like my random
forests and wanted a logistic I can
literally just replace the random forest
with the
logistic in that one Lego block and the
rest of the tower is fine it's going to
do all the same transformations feed the
same thing and I'm just using a
different algorithm that's awesome
that makes it way easier for me to play
with things and tune things um as I get
to in a moment about grid search it it's
just it's fun it's fast it's lazy not
wait tracking the interactions and the
hierarchy of ensembles models so
ensemble is models when you get into
like some of these cackle competitions
you get like 300 models predicting the
inputs for another 200 models 210 models
and that's your answer and that's crazy
so how would you keep track of that I
wouldn't I I'd keep track of with this
obviously the whole talk is about this
it's super important to be able to
actually track where all these things
are going and coming pipelines this was
called why I heart pipelines right as
the section title not tracking
intermediate data allows for easy model
stacking so this could also be
considered ensemble egde but you could
use like principal component analysis
select your principal components and
feed those into a random forest right
automatically you can slap them together
so you don't accidentally like save it
somewhere in your code and then later
call the wrong one because it was v2 and
this happens all the time it's great I
prepare ammeter opposition model tuning
pipelines support in fact are heavily
integrated with grid search grid search
grid searches awesome grid search is
simple over using the words simple grid
search is awesome let's stick with that
earlier we apply I'm going to look at
the pipelines named steps which is a
dictionary and the keys I hope we all
remember factor extractor fill in a
converts a dataframe
random forest classifier
I know we're looking at code right this
is just brutal um what a grid search
does is it's just going to say hey how
many trees do you want and I'm like well
is it better with 100 trees or 250 trees
you just give it a list of parameters
and it's going to run on each of those
it's gonna tell you which one was most
accurate awesome how do I say hey I have
this huge Lego tower and I want you to
adjust two blocks here here and here
you use prid search like this so in this
parameters dictionary right god someone
can read it somewhat no that's fine the
slides aren't posted anywhere I could
send them out though the dictionary
reads random forest classifier double
underscore and estimators so all this
thing is doing is scanning through your
parameter dictionary saying okay I'm
gonna find names of actual objects
inside here and then I'm going to look
for a double underscore signifies that
we're going to level deeper and then
just hand that parameter to that actual
step you could go as deep as you want
with double underscores right because
all of these can nest and nest the nest
you can pass it all throughout here and
you could you could mess with you
principal component analysis at the same
time I create a grid search object I
feed it an estimator normally would be
like a random forest in this case it's
the whole pipeline right age filling all
that and then I feed it a parameter grid
which is just a simple dictionary
a simple again I should watch that grid
search dot fit it's going to fit itself
on this training data it's going to fit
it three times because the default
cross-validation is three and it has
three different candidates right this
earlier list of 100 250 and 300 three
times three is nine my dad and I are
gonna be on the same page for this part
you get a fit grid search object from
there you can pull out what the best
estimator was what each of the different
scores were you do all kinds of stuff
key point here is I just fed it the
whole pipeline I didn't have to feed it
like an individual piece of the pipeline
cool publishing models so we've done all
this model development I'm not running
out of time totally but we're kind of
getting there you want to publish this
model maybe you have a deployment
process to s3 github maybe it's a floppy
disk you can just save this fit model
object to disk and it's really just job
Lib dump right pipeline name of the
thing you want to dump it's gonna write
a bunch of files cuz this is a random
forest you're going to treat that first
pickled file PKL that's your main object
when you load it later
spoilers when you load it later you're
gonna point at that same file right but
you can do anything with these at this
point this is an actual artifact and the
artifact is not just the model logic it
is all of that feature engineering logic
and your fit model object I'm going to
go stress that point a bunch more so
let's move on let's talk about
deployment otherwise known as the
three-ish slides you've already waited
like 30 minutes to see because this is
the name of the talk uh handing it off
right you've got an entire pipeline
safety disk it could be anywhere at
GrubHub we post them to like asset
buckets on s3 this is not a secret this
is simple easy fun to access fun for all
ages I don't know all your deployed
model needs to do is be loaded from disk
into memory and had predict or predict
probably called on that object I can't
stress this enough you don't have to
retrain your model alright you want to
score new data you do not have to
retrain your model you've made like a
Java jar you've actually created a fit
object um this is the most common
mistake I see and it's super common and
it's super obvious because at some point
you have a new department and you want
to say hey I have a bunch of code it
creates a model that then you can feed
data to and get a score from and predict
fraud and they're like great let's put
it in production so you're like here's
my Python code and so they put it in
production your Python code trains the
whole model and then call score or
predict or predict prob a what-have-you
um super common I wanted to really make
sure that this point was made so I put
myself a second notes to emphasize this
point you don't have to retrain it right
this is like rebuilding a car from
scratch before driving it every time you
drive it we can talk a lot about model
retraining like how often should you do
it and such if your model let's say is a
daily prediction
and you're retraining it everyday on the
newest day of data you're prone to
overfitting um if you're trying to
predict who is sick based on hospital
records and they're testing based on
your model suddenly your model is eating
its own tail right because they're only
testing ones you've said maybe you
should just publish your model once on
that old data and maybe just retrain a
model in parallel and see how they
differ or if they're the same this sort
of thing isn't thought about a lot in my
past and now it's really important to me
that you actually really make sure you
just use that same model cool loading
from disk I did spoil this already um
let's say we have some totally random
model job Lib code it's a thin card our
fit pipeline pickle we now have some
totally random model it's got some named
steps it's got some keys yeah they kind
of look familiar it's like we published
it minutes ago this is really cool this
is extremely cool you can see everything
that's is inside there so some totally
random model dot steps gives me access
to the steps and then it's just a list
of them right so I take one which is the
second step because we're zero indexed
and I get fill n/a the name and filling
a the function with any replacement
equals 28 I can't tell you how much time
and effort that saves me there are stuff
that is deployed in production running
someone come soon you're like hey what's
where we were placing those nulls with
if you go back to your training code are
you a hundred percent sure that you're
gonna get that same value because you
can rewind your data and also recreated
and know for sure what was even put to
production which is great but are you
sure you can if it's some other
co-worker and they got a new job or
they're on vacation and there's like
maybe 30 different features and they
have file sets that read like final
underscore to underscore not this one
right like I have we not seen this I see
this all the time it's a pain um in an
ideal world you wouldn't need any of
this
you wouldn't I'd all have to double
check this you'd have beautiful version
control and Jenkins deployments galore
and it would be great
but in the real world pulling the actual
object back into your local database and
being like so what what was this thing
is really powerful
it really makes you move fast
I think I hit everything yeah ah data
scientists are not data engineers data
engineers are not data scientists you
can bring around coffee and doughnuts or
you can give them like a standard object
either way you're gonna make real good
friends with some data engineers this
way they don't want to deal with all of
your [ __ ] they're specialists I'm
skipping some things I'll come back um
they're specialists right so everything
that a data engineer doesn't know about
data science you equally don't know
about data engineering right they have
their own iceberg of things below the
surface that are complicated and
interesting if they want to work on this
handoff you want to keep it low friction
you don't want to hold bespoke process
built out every single time the new
models ready to be deployed right so if
you have infrastructure as an engineer
that takes an object loads it from
memory oh this is going to my process
I'm skipping all over loads it from
memory
grab some new data calls the predict
method of the object on the new data and
outputs it they don't really want to
worry about like were you predicting
fraud or were you predicting customer
click-through if it's just a pipeline
you get that this is just standardizing
infrastructure this makes it really easy
but my stuff doesn't exist in a pipeline
you might say you can write a wrapper
for it I might say right this is really
easy and it makes your engineers happy
are there going to be bespoke processes
of course everything is going to have
some exceptions but if 90% of your stuff
goes this way we're talking deployments
that take minutes not like months or
days this is really straightforward
I hope I'm just gonna keep repeating
until you believe me that's really the
approach I have at this point oh right
I've had this happen to me if your data
engineer is on vacation it's really nice
if you want to like have something in
prod and you don't have to like spend
two weeks training the new data engineer
if they're just like oh yeah I see where
they're just standard object or they're
being but a boom you're you're you're
there you got it
just trust me it was awesome
why I heart pipelines part two this is
the development right was part one this
is the deployment side tests can be
written against pipelines you can have
standard inputs you can get the output
save the output compare the output from
then on in every model version see if
they change this is important
models are backed up in version control
again modeling codes should be backed up
in version control having the literal
object in version control is just an
extra once against any sort of failures
re running the model that you did last
December and a certain version is
amazing I'm hoping you can also rewind
your data to that point that's also
really C rescore it is often really
important this different types of my
career has been more or less like the
vendor break peers can check out your
model and test it
having peers being able to actually
interact with your own model objects is
really important it means you can
actually get some feedback and just like
- an engineer it's a standard object to
an engineer it's or to a scientist it's
also a standard object they know how to
load it
then you'll had to start piecing it
apart instead of like a huge amount of
Python code that you're trying to read
through and figure out what they
actually did this gives you that end
result as an object cool open source is
really cool this applies to all kinds of
open source things you can write your
own extensions like I did with this data
frame Union right I can see the source
code I can read it I can adapt it and
now I've got my own little thing um you
can hire people who are already familiar
with pipelines this is not unique to
pipelines obviously this is the whole
open-source community and this is a big
win in the open-source community you can
actually hire people who are familiar
everyone has homegrown systems they
exist they're natural using less and
less it's really really fast to get
people on board it and you can
collaborate across teams departments
even companies right I get in arguments
with random folks at different companies
about these exact same things and
there's a whole community out there
there's Stack Overflow pages solving
these problems there are not cover foe
pages solving my homegrown company's
tools problems as much wish there were
this kind of community out there this
kind of supports being able to work with
different people is really awesome cool
so what I hope you walk away with I kind
of wouldn't ask a layer pipeline looks
like yeah Legos
maybe where you use SK learn pipelines
protip everywhere you probably know that
I think pipelines are really awesome at
this point and we all would probably
agree that my father still has no idea
what I do day to day go that's all my
talk
the question is when debugging if
there's something thrown at the top of
this tower when I called the whole thing
um is there some way to really get at
that naturally um it does give you the
trace back of the actual like container
with through it and if you're having
other trouble all I'll do is I'll just
snip off the top three blocks or however
many and call transform on those three
because they will actually transform
right above the bad one to be like oh
the IMP is full of nulls it's not
transformers fault it's right above it
being able to just take is definitely
how I debug these things
jigna is why did I roll my own class for
extra boost classifier because he thinks
that the classifier has an SK learn
class that implements these things as
well two answers one I needed to have it
for the ensemble egde so I had to have
some sort of model transformer to call
transform and translate that to predict
to the model object
- I didn't Google enough I had no idea
that existed
the question is why use pipelines or
where to use them
so the difference between kind of blue
pipelines and tasks and wrapping it
there versus the SK learn one I have
built both I've had Luigi tasks which
are like like a dag right like a
directed acyclic graph these different
tasks are just calling each other the
code from SK learn was literally just an
object that is pulled in and called on
so the task is more of a like system
level operation these SK learned
pipelines are more of just the object so
when you're using these tasks you might
say like tasks a transform the data by
setting age null equal to this task B do
this test C do this instead you could
just say task a coma pipeline kind of
you can do both it's really just a
clarity issue at that point and I can
talk more in detail later if you want
they serve different roles I guess
that's really where I'd say thing else
Beck yes oh sorry I suggested that you
can use grid search on top of a pipeline
the question was can you also use that
inside of a feature Union and the answer
is yes
I have
the question is does that become expect
computationally if you have a bunch of
different inside of your feature Union
and these have different pram um yes
because you are running it you know 27
400 times and you can tweak some of that
around as needed you can run those
different model tunings like if you have
a bunch of different parameters you can
currently can spin up some big server
and just call parallel eyes and have at
it the question is will it will it call
it and basically a Cartesian join of all
the possible combinations for randomize
CV yes there are other forms of grid
search that do different things but yeah
that Cartesian join it really is
searching that Cartesian space of every
possible combination I don't know I just
go home and come in the next day like I
just like a rotten this actually goes
back to my earlier point though right
we're like the pipeline object that's
computationally expensive if you
but if you run it once over the weekend
you come back in in 72 hours later or
something it's done 48 so weekend yeah
let me did a scientist um at that point
you can publish this final fit object
and from then on you're just pulling it
down right and then you just calling
score and it takes less than a second
and that's a big win of actually being
able to use these other questions I have
no time so one is great